Take it hard to go
Let them teach you how to do
What's it take to get you out there?
What's it take to bring you home?
All the small things
True care, true dreams
I'll take one left
You're right, that's true
Always, I know
You'll be at my show
Rising, waiting
Come with serenity
Say it ain't too late
Let's go OG fans!
Welcome your team back to the pitch!
Take it hard to go
What's it take to get you out there?
Take it hard to get you out there!
Welcome your team back to the pitch!
Let's go OG fans!
Let's go
We need more excuses now
I'm talking here and now
Let's go
Cause I'm running now, I'm talking here and now, I'm talking here and now
It's not about what you've done, it's about what you're doing
It's all about where you're going, no matter where you're going
Let's go